ladies and gentlemen this is the boy who
cried story fire now let me say right up
front this is gonna be a tough line for
me to walk
because it's a story i think should be
told but it's also
a balance okay because there's some
juicy lies
things in here that normally i would
make fun of it really get some enjoyment
out of some laughs out of
but at the same time i also believe in
this guy's mission
this is jesse one of the co-founders of
storyfire um
and it's basically an alt youtube
platform now there's not a youtuber on
earth
that doesn't want to see alternate
youtube platforms succeed
because that gives us more competition
it makes us less beholden
to um youtube and if we ever get kicked
off because you guys know there's all
sorts of platforms that happen
all the time we're not stuck basically
in no man's land right so we want to see
this guy succeed i'm no exception so i
believe in their mission
and yet in the past couple weeks they
have
basically staged a publicity stunt and
i'm gonna argue
for why it was what it was uh of story
fire shutting down actually i should say
it another way
it wasn't a lie they maybe intended for
it to shut down
but they created it into a publicity
stunt
lie to their fans and honestly behave
so childishly that they're losing the
trust of this audience that
wants them to succeed and i'm just
hoping that this video may help push
home
a point that a lot of people are feeling
right now which is
guys just stop lying
story fire is shutting down february 1st
okay so this is all how it starts now
you guys may know uh jesse from another
video
that we did which he's going to address
right now which is his latest in a
series of kind of
fictionalizations dramatizations lies i
mean i don't know what you want to call
it i know after a statement like that
you guys are probably thinking of back
when i quit youtube just a year ago
and said january 1st 2020 i'm leaving
youtube this is not clickbait it's a
very real video
we're having to shut down the platform
yeah you heard that right uh
almost a year ago he did another
marketing stunt
which he calls it clickbait but in his
promotional video about it he said it
wasn't clickbait
this is not a clickbait video he said
i'm leaving youtube
100 i'll die i will die
by the fire that is my guarantee to you
i will
die by the fire now i use this in a
video about how creators fake their own
retirement you may remember it
but now he's saying oh that video that
was a marketing stunt this is totally
different guys you can trust me
and because of that you know everyone
listened with baited breath
for why story fire was shutting down
everyone was so bummed about it i
offered a million dollars
to keep this platform going another year
however unfortunately brian declined uh
brian being
one of the other founders founding
partner of storyfire and unfortunately
there's not much i can do
yeah he basically throws his uh
co-founder to the bus in this video
where he's saying about how he needs to
shut it down he accuses him
of stealing money actually from the
platform uh which is later retracted but
this whole video was very strange and
felt like
off i found out that like brian was uh
taking some of the 30 percent of the
story fire creator revenue so
storyboard is a 30-70 split brian was
dipping into that
and paying himself out independently and
it really kind of broke the trust
um and then all of a sudden out of
nowhere of course in the last
final hour before they're shut down
after all everyone's gotten sad about it
everyone you know
gets everyone makes videos about it
farewell
videos everyone's you know bummed that a
youtube alternative is shut down
this guy goes we landed investment
capital on the literal last day of story
fire
existing wow what an american story an
all-american story and he post this
video
story fire has been saved now there's
obviously still a lot of
problems with the platform right you
just accused your co-founder of theft
but wow let's hear about this uh this
investor this mystery investor that you
landed you know that investor have you
heard of him
oh a mystery investor yes wait how the
[ __ ] do you know him
he's my boy i've hung out with him the
time he's from the same
okay right he saw your video
call me about it was like what is going
on so he's
offered to throw some cash
and i actually want to throw some cash
wow a christmas miracle guys they land
investment capital and obviously nobody
can believe it right bro
you bring this other guy in you're dead
ass dead ass this is not a joke dude
this is no drama this ain't some you
know
trying to hear that you're that this
isn't some kind of fake thing
this ain't no drama this is real you
understand how bad this looks though
that we're saying with a shutdown
everyone's going to think this bs it's
because later
we realize it is well it's not okay but
it is though
it actually is listen you can't run a
real company if you're gonna lie
to the people who trust you
guys this is not wait what the [ __ ]
guys this is real life this is real life
okay pause let's skip ahead
in our story it's gonna be a non-linear
story guys trying some new storytelling
here
just freeze frame there this is the same
guy
a few days later with something about
like the truth about storyfire which i
thought we already heard the truth
the last two weeks have been absolutely
insane the video that i made on the day
of shutdown
was obviously dramatized uh me rolling
around in the snow
that's me the mcjuggernuggets character
being ridiculous
really this is the problem
are you are you seeing this this guy's
screaming in one video this is a hundred
percent real
you guys can trust me guys i wouldn't
joke around with something so serious
it's a serious thing this is my business
and then later on
he says guys didn't you not obviously a
joke obviously you guys weren't supposed
to believe me when i said that we landed
investment capital in literally the last
day of story fire
we did it you know we saved it um it
almost doesn't matter how
but i don't want you to always just
think of like either it's fake or real
usually the truth is somewhere in the
messy middle like like
no absolutely not maybe for a
you know a fun narrative series the
truth is
based on a true story right not for a
business if you're expecting people to
back you up
if you're expecting people to believe in
you you can't go to them and say oh yeah
the part when i said this is a hundred
percent true
i thought you would know that the truth
is sort of
somewhere somewhere in the middle that
just can't fly
uh now this is the part that was not
factual
okay okay here we go is and and i'll
explain why
there was no investor no investor came
to save the day
i wish
it was me again i put in more
money okay at this point he said he put
in like three million dollars already to
the platform
so i don't know if he put in another for
like another million dollars or
something like that
and i don't want to like mock this on
the one hand it's admirable that you
feel so strongly
about your company um but at the same
time
if you put in money then what was the
whole shutdown thing about
it was really about your own
indecisiveness about whether you wanted
to continue running your company
and brian spitz whether he wanted to
take the money for more equity in the
company
but nothing had to do with like external
forces of we were saved whatever
it was you guys as business partners not
communicating
and then basically deciding let's just
pour more money into this and lose more
money
hoping that it will succeed now again i
hope it does succeed
but how can you back a guy that is
constantly talking about
some hypothetical investor that doesn't
exist yeah and you're putting your money
on the line so this dude's serious this
time
modeling on the line and one of the most
badass investors out there so we have to
make this work dude dude
i mean yo just to hop on a call with him
he's talking about hopping on a call
with himself because to be clear this is
the guy that put in more money so he's
going
to hop on a call with this investor oh
my gosh i would be so lucky
to be on a call with him right now i'm
like i'll be shaking
it's all real guys i'm gonna go walk on
this lake finally
unfortunately um this is why actually
that
people are so suspicious in the first
place is that this is just not the first
time he's done
it i mean it's not even even the
quitting youtube thing wasn't the first
time he did
this fake thing and unfortunately he's
in a boy who cried wolf situation where
he's
he's said things and said this is 100
real guys
for so long that nobody believes you
anymore and unfortunately
i won't either the next time you say
something whatever
i actually was i very publicly tweeted
that i didn't believe him
um but you know you just lose trust in
people like this because it's
unacceptable when talking about a
business to be like well the truth
somewhere in the middle 100 real but
then afterwards be like guys it's
obviously fake duh can you address the
people calling it fake
i think it's i think it's a lot because
like i said over the years
i've done a lot of narrative series it's
hard for people to know when i'm in
character
out of character and that's fair yeah
it's because you don't tell people
you say it's 100 real and it's 100 not
um on top of the fact this was a
miraculous
thing that happened in in the final
moments
and it's hard for people to believe when
something so crazy happens
no you just decided to put more of your
money in i want to be clear
this was not a miracle this was you
deciding i'm going to sink more money
into my project my baby
before deciding whether to put an end to
it right which
again admirable love that you're doing
this it's hard to back this though you
know
when it comes to narrative stuff it's
not very creative
i wouldn't i wouldn't [ __ ] with that
idea oh here he's talking about how he
would never do a narrative
about this to also be like a sit-down
video saying it's
shutting down versus um
like there's no point to it you know i
don't see what the
substance the wow the creative
narrative or the lessons learned there's
not much it's literally me sitting
down saying yo it's shutting down
because
it is like it was a real video um
and that's everybody i wouldn't want to
[ __ ] with everybody who's so invested in
the platform that wouldn't be right
so here he's kind of splitting hairs and
wants to have you know
have his cake and eat it too because his
whole thing is like well the shutdown
was real we were gonna really shut it
down
the only thing that i faked was
everything else
which was all the excitement around the
thing but you're saying right here that
you would never do that and clearly you
did
so you probably feel the same way i do
which is like
i want to believe in this thing i want
to believe in another youtube platform
it's hard because you know there's
they're going up against so much but
everybody wants to believe in the david
vs goliath story
it's just you know just don't don't lie
to us um and it just it's kind of almost
offensive in a way that you guys would
think that of me
and to know that every story that i've
ever told on youtube and everything that
i've ever done that was in
narrative or in character was to impart
a good lesson or to tell a good story
so it's offensive for us to think that
maybe this isn't real
but you're trying to impart a lesson so
what is the lesson here i i think the
lesson is actually that
you're not trustworthy right now you
need to tell people that either you're
done with this like
character that you're playing and you're
just gonna play business with business
characters with your story like this
whole like i'm gonna
mix storytelling and my business it just
doesn't work unless you tell people
right up front
and this would be fine like be like hey
this is fake right i'm dramatizing my
business whatever but instead
he's rolling around in the snow saying
this is real yeah i'm like
there was no investor it was me and that
is the story guys
of the boy who cried story fire it's an
interesting story for sure and it
conflicts me obviously for obvious
reasons so uh yeah that being said just
let jesse play himself out here and uh
that's it see in the next one it sucks
because like
everyone's like this is a theory guys
this is real this is actually like a
real thing everyone said
like their goodbyes a lot of people left
i don't think people understand
what's just happened everyone's gonna
think i'm a fake mother
but regardless regardless i don't know
these investors
i mean i know i know i just don't know
i don't know anybody else
[Music]
nothing but a trick trying to sell me on
a dream but that was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee
you just want my dollar bills i got this
funny feel that what you made of who you
are is really nothing real
you trying
[Music]
never stop until there's no more